Watson who is David McCullough correct
IBM's Watson technology that beat two
humans on Jeopardy two years ago maybe
the technology that helps doctors beat
cancer
dr. Arthur Forney at West med Medical
Group in New York is testing Watson in
the form of an iPad app during its pilot
phase so here Watson was given a very
unusual case a young asian woman
nonsmoker
who has lung cancer so now you you tell
Watson to do its thing
and it's now looking at the data you
inputted the data from her imaging from
her biopsy in 17 seconds Watson it
analyzed about 3,500 text books and
400,000 other pieces of data this is the
screen where it shows you that after
looking at what you have so far
it would consider that you do several
other things for the patient that it
doesn't see yet in the chart in an
instant Watson has figured out what
caused this cancer it turns out she has
a very rare genetic mutation which is
accounting for her cancer and offered
three treatment options it has shown
that treatment one has a 95 percent
confidence of being effective whereas
treatment 2 is only half that is so
obscure that you would have needed
Watson for the diagnosis and treatment
or an oncologist come up with the same
treatment in fact this is such a new
discovery of this particular mutation
and it's a relatively new drug as well
that my guess is that many oncologists
may not be quite up to speed yet Watson
gets its wisdom from dr. Andrew Seidman
and a team at New York's Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center 1,500 lung
cancer cases so far and breast cancer
cases as well lab results physicians
notes and clinical research have been
fed into the supercomputer along with
medical journals and textbooks we are
trying to challenge Watson right now in
the training process with common cases
and not so common cases
so the Watson system that we built is in
is a machine that's about this size
we've done a lot of engineering on that
fence and Watson chief technology
officer Rob hi says the achievement is
staggering Watson learns about language
and that's the really profound
breakthrough here is that it is in the
language that we understand each other
that breakthrough and Watson's
remarkable accuracy could help doctors
eliminate unnecessary procedures and
costs and disrupt the 2.8 trillion
dollar health care industry it's the
partnership between physician and
patient between information technology
and the healthcare environment I think
it is a game changer it can aid the
physician in a way that's nothing we've
ever had before this is so fascinating
you know they said they're giving Watson
more and more challenges how is Watson
doing so far you know with cases ranging
from the common to the exceptionally
unique so far Watson's accuracy is
remarkable they expect nothing lower
than 85% to 95% and so far it has proven
out to hit those numbers it really is
amazing they wanted that for Jeopardy
and they're seeing it again with the
cancer so what about when then I mean
there's all this talk about Watson's
potential when is Watson going to be
ready to treat people it's pretty close
they're continuing the beta test they
think they'll be done by around the end
of the year in patients could start
using it doctors